DAVE GOSSARD: The world around us,
both natural and man-made, is in
constant motion.
Understanding the dynamic behavior of
objects and systems, their motions and
associated forces, is fundamental
to engineering.
The ability to analyze and predict the
dynamic behavior of mechanical systems
is an important foundation for
design and innovation.
Hi, I'm Dave Gossard, professor of
mechanical engineering at MIT and
instructor of a new course
on edX, 2.03x, Dynamics.
This course has the same rigor as the
regular MIT course of the same name,
one of the first subjects in our
mechanical engineering undergraduate
curriculum.
In this course, you will learn to apply
Newton's laws to systems whose
complexity is representative
of engineering practice.
You will learn to analyze the kinematics
of mechanisms, understand
torque and angular momentum, and
imbalance in rotating systems.
You'll learn to derive equations of
motion for nonlinear dynamic systems
and how to use modern computational
tools to solve them.
After completing this course, you'll
be able to analyze the behavior of
existing devices you encounter
and predict the behavior of
new ones you invent.
It'll be fun, accessible,
and empowering.
Come join us in 2.03x and get moving.
[MUSIC PLAYING]